I can't think of a single issue that,
uh,
democrats should draw.
W,
which American be I usually Democrats
portray America,
the beautiful a should we say,
listen,
we don't care about American beautiful
anymore.
We're going to get in bed with the oil
spills and the clear cutters and the
mountain top removal and the people who
want to destroy America's beauty for
profit don't want to portray that value.
I taught my kids to sing the song.
I should probably stick up for it.
Which,
which American badge,
which we,
we,
we try.
Uh,
you've got,
uh,
the Statue of Liberty.
May we just knocked that over a little,
a little mall there,
a little strip mall with Sasha.
Used to be so we can join the anti
immigrant crowd.
No,
the statue says,
give me your tired.
Give me your poor,
your huddled masses yearning to breathe
free.
If that sentiment was good enough for
our grandparents,
it should be good enough for our
grandchildren.
The color of the immigrants might
change.
Our national values should not change
that we are a nation of immigrants.
We should be respectful of the
contribution of immigrants.
And you cannot be an anti immigrant,
bigot and a Patriot at the same time.
Those are things that don't go together.
We're supposed to give that up.
We're supposed to give up the idea of
liberty and justice for all.
Okay?
We,
we believe in liberty and justice for
all.
Just not for the gay people.
You know,
just leave them out or you're not for
the poor urban black kids.
Leave them out.
We'll,
we'll give them a justice based on their
hoodies are wearing rather than based on
what they're actually doing is.
I mean,
which American value are we supposed to
betray?
Um,
I'm not going to betray any of them.
I think we should have liberty and
justice for all.
I think we should honor honor the,
not just a statue of liberty as a
symbol,
but as also the substance,
uh,
that,
that statue stands for.
I think we should believe in America,
the beautiful end offend America.
But I'm not willing to give up any
American values to appease people who,
if you gave up those values,
they would move 10 feet 10 more feet to
the right.
Anyway.
Anybody who
is in public life needs to find out what
they believe in and in public life will
test you.
You may think you know what you believe
in until you get put over those hot
coals,
the public life.
Some people believe that Americans just
as this land of,
of,
of individuals who have a lot of liberty
and she'd be left alone because how we
got so great,
I can't find any evidence that that's a
true story.
Best I can tell.
The American Century,
the last century when,
when everybody looks at with such awe
wasn't built by a bunch of random
individuals who didn't care about each
other and when do anything for each
other and the government that was
missing in action that was built by us
pooling our resources,
uh,
mainly through government,
massively investing in infrastructure,
public schools and dams and roads and
bridges and education.
Educating a whole generation of young
people at a level and scaled.
Never been done before.
Building a middle class.
It had a labor rights and civil rights
and women's rights to make sure that
middleclass could include more and more
people.
Making sure that we were no longer
poisoning the air and the water,
taking care of our children,
making sure that industry wasn't
poisoned,
killing our kids.
That is what made this great American
century that everybody's so off.
It wasn't just individual liberty or
just a market economic performance.
Lots of countries care about economic
growth,
but they have no environmental
protections in the labor standards.
That's not America.
America is a great country because we
perform well economically and meet those
standards,
but also we meet high environmental
standards and high consumer protection
standards and high civil rights,
Labor inclusions.
Here we are.
We're a worldclass across the board.
That's why people want to come here,
not just because we got to hire a big
GNP,
you'd have great gmp and have people
working as wet shops and have water and
the air poison that's not America and so
when you look at that as the kind of
country that we are,
then you say,
I'm going to defend that.
I'm going to defend my parents
achievements.
I'm going to defend my grandparents
I'm not going to let people take a
wrecking ball painted red,
white,
and blue,
and smashed down every American
achievement for the last century and
call that patriotism.
In my view,
it's not patriotism in my view.
Patriotism and frankly being a
conservative would mean you would
conserve the achievements of our parents
and our grandparents.
They achieved the American Century,
the American middle class,
the American way of life.
It includes a,
an appropriately active government.
It also includes a dynamic private
sector.
It also includes community
responsibility and individual
responsibility,
but all of those together,
not just free markets and and,
and,
and starved this America's government so
they can't do its job.
And so we have a responsibility,
I think,
to go forward and stand up for what we
believe in.
Whether we're running for office like
some are or whether we're not like
myself.
We have a responsibility to defend the
America that we inherited and to make
sure that,
that people calling themselves patriots
don't smash them.